[ __ ] senior political analyst britt hume
knew her well for many years 38 years
and he joins us tonight right what did
you make of Barbara Bush she was a woman
of enormous character she adored her
husband and I always had the sense in
seeing them together that she never
could quite get enough of him that he
was such a gregarious man he had so many
friends and he people liked him and he
liked people and that there was never
quite enough of him to go around as far
as she was concerned and of course she
was as was mentioned in Bill Clinton's
statement we just saw on the air a few
minutes ago she it was a fierce person
and this was not a mellow first lady
this was a woman of strong views and yet
she managed Tucker for all that not to
really ever be a controversial first
lady she just wasn't and I think it was
because people saw her character and
admired her and she was indeed admirable
boy looking at the tape of her on the
screen you you you really note how much
America is changing how she was really
representative of a country that and
values that aren't as common as they
once were maybe they've almost
disappeared she was as you said famous
without being controversial how does she
pull that off well I think if it was
obvious I think to people who saw her
heard her speak saw her in action and
watch the way she behaved that she
behaved with a certain dignity and grace
befitting the wife of a prominent figure
than a wife obviously of a president
later as the mother of a president that
there was so she had that she had that
quality that was wood which I think
people respected and she also had a
better and obvious goodwill and I think
that's shown through in a way that was
unmistakable so that people saw those
things in her and she really never
struck a false note I mean there was a
moment when when during the 1988
campaign when Geraldine Ferraro had
excuse me this was I guess it was during
the the the 1984 campaign yeah her
husband had debated Geraldine Ferraro
during the reagan reelection campaign
against Walter Mondale and she said that
in Ferrara came across as somebody whose
net who could be described as rhyming
with rich and that was immediately taken
this to mean [ __ ] but she later
clarified that she meant only which but
people if people thought that was
improper they quickly forgave her for
that and she she went on to become
exceedingly popular and well-liked I
will say this you never had the feeling
about her that if you had your your
shirt untucked or your you're a little
out of order that she wasn't gonna
notice and I remember being at a state
dinner you know the the the customers
always if you're in the member of the
White House press corps that there's a
certain number of tickets that the press
office can give out and I got to go to
one at one time and my dinner partner
was the was the retired tennis pro then
Chris Evert who was a friend of the Bush
family and she had on this very short
gold evening dress and the word reached
me pretty quickly that mrs. Bush was not
amused by that dress me I thought it was
wonderful well if you talk mean her son
the president would go on at some length
about what a ferocious figure she was
and she must have been you knew her of
course in Washington covering the family
knew the family in Florida and also in
Maine I mean you spent a lot of time
around a bunch of different parts of the
Bush family she was at the center of it
kind of a remarkable family a remarkable
family what was her role in the family
well she was well she was the you know
obviously she's the matriarch right
because you know she's the the mother
the grandmother the wife of the
president and she was a she was she was
strong not mellow in the way that that
her husband was and so if those boys and
and and their sister growing up you know
stepped out of line it was pretty clear
who they were more afraid of she was you
know she was starchy dignified old line
New England aristocratic all those
things and and and people loved her and
you could say in this political
atmosphere where everybody's supposed to
be so egalitarian that that they loved
or in spite of that but I rather
happened to think they loved her because
of it that's exactly right
I wonder if they're space or something
like that in modern
American life well I think so if you
behaved with grace and dignity and and
decorum and obvious goodwill and and you
know that people are gonna respect that
and she know she had she had that and
she also had that countenance you know
with the white hair which she had from
quite a young age that's why I guess it
was her husband a dubbed her the Silver
Fox and so she was known to many people
by that sobriquet and and she'd kind of
lived that part you know she was she was
quite a figure and she's a real loss to
the country and I can only think about
how her husband must be feeling tonight
because they were so close Tucker I mean
I didn't see a lot of them in recent
years but when I did when they were
together there was one thing that was
always going on they were holding hands
yes she was you know she had she had
portable oxygen oxygen the last several
times I saw her he was getting around as
best she could and of course he's and he
was you know he's quite ill and is
believed by the family to be in the you
know the latter stages of his life I
sort of I don't know that it was
anticipated by many people outside the
family that she would that she would pre
decease him as has now happened but I
can only imagine the sense of loss he
must feel tonight and I think you know
to all of us our hearts go out to the to
him and to the rest of the Bush family
tonight
a great lady has died we're looking at
pictures outside the Bush family home in
Texas we just saw a video a minute ago a
Barbara Bush with her then famous
springer spaniel Millie a reminder that
she was a great lover of Springer
Spaniels one of the best things about
her or anyone I would say but she must
have also as you pointed out which is
with her husband all the time she travel
with him she was the head not just of a
family but of a very political family
what was her political Sensibility I
mean she must have had a sense of it
being around it her whole life oh I
don't I don't think there's much doubt
about that and of course she had a pet
issue literacy which there was she had a
number of issues and causes that she's
supporting literacy was the one that was
the most conspicuous and in fact I went
over to help to be the emcee at the 75th
anniversary of Pearl Harbor a year ago
last December and
and and that was at the bush library the
bush 41 library in College Station Texas
and the first night we were there she
was not there because she was away at a
literacy event with her son Neil so that
was the cause that she never lost sight
of and was a part of world by the time
by the way that that I saw there the
Springer Spaniels were out of the
picture and she had a couple of these
little dogs that went with her
everywhere she'd go and you could always
tell apparently when she was gonna come
into a room because he would be preceded
by the dogs and and they kept an eye on
things she liked that our dogs get
smaller as we age I've noticed that I'm
not evil but that was a wonderful
summation of an amazing life and I
appreciate thank you yeah Thank You
Tucker